Welcome back everyone, this is my Thor 5 video
Chris Hemsworth just
announced this would be his last Marvel movie
as Thor like his last time as the character so
I'll explain what that means given the Hercules
post-credits scene and Thor 11 Thunder what
that's meant to set up for Thor's next movie
and separately how that's all connected to
Avengers six Secret Wars because even though
Chris Hemsworth is talking about leaving
the character after his next movie that's
not meant to be about Secret Wars that's like
a whole separate movie from what the Hercules
post-credits scene is meant to set up what is
Chris Hemsworth's last Marvel movie and it may
be my last I don't know it was a wild and fun and
wacky experience as all played that character for
10 11 years now and each time it's been new and
exciting and and this this was no exception to
that it felt very fresh and it felt like we were
trying something we hadn't tried before he wasn't
quite himself and he had some work to do so he
leaves that film and embarks on a journey of
self-discovery and that's where we picked this up
if you're brand new to the channel I'll do Marvel
videos every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'll be doing videos for Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special next week it's a
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 prequel we're also going
to start getting Ant-Man 3 quantumania trailers
really soon because that movie is coming out at
the beginning of next year it's like the next big
movie and talking more about the lead up into the
next Avengers movies that's sort of the beginning
of this Kang Multiverse New Avengers stuff all
coming together in a clearer way Marvel Phase
5 is sort of like the marches they bring them
all slowly together by the end of Marvel Phase 5
so the beginning of Marvel phase six there is a
version of The New Avengers team that'll start
to happen in Captain America 4 New World Order
like the Falcon Captain America will slowly start
putting his quote-unquote team together and that
is the new Avengers team and currently right
now Thor is one of the few remaining original
core Avengers I Define the core Avengers as the
original six Because by the time Avengers Infinity
War happened the roster had ballooned to way
bigger like you got Roadies Scarlet Witch Vision
a bunch of other characters I just did a bunch of
Captain America 4 New World Order and Thunderbolts
videos because there's a big world war Hulk plot
big Hulk related plot that's flowing through those
with red Hulk with Bruce Banner's Hulk and
with scar son of Hulk just in terms of Chris
Hemsworth's character we last saw him at the end
of Thor love and thunder and at the end of that
movie he agreed to raise Gore's resurrected
now superchild named love resurrected by
eternity the child of Eternity that's where her
superpowers came from their little undecided a
little vague about how her powers work she just
has blanket superpowers that allow her to wield
Stormbreaker without it melting her brain there's
no worthiness enchantment on Stormbreaker so
anybody could walk around and pick it up but the
problem is you have to be powerful enough or the
power flowing through the actual ax will melt
your brain that's why only people like Thanos
people like Captain America with some level of
superpowers can pick it up and be just fine Thor
agrees to raise her to at least adolescence till
she decides to take off on her own she's played
by Chris Hemsworth's real life daughter too and
she's about eight years old or so when they made
the movie and they just go on adventures together
around the universe helping people giving the move
be its title they are both love and thunder
going around helping people here's where we
start to get to the plot of the next Thor movie
like love will not be a big character in that but
when the events of the movie pick up Thor will
still be doing what he's doing now going around
helping people the Jane Foster stuff sacrificing
herself and then going to Valhalla when she dies
is also meant to be more of an Avengers six
Secret Wars teaser eventually she will come
back per the rules they set up in Moon night I
think the reason she ended up there is because
she formed a contract with a hammer like even
though Moon Knight himself did not believe in
the Egyptian afterlife he formed a contract
with conchu to become Moon Knight and that's
why he wound up in the duod as far as I know she
Heimdall the original Loki from the 616 Marvel
Universe not coming back during Thor 5 is always
possible but I think it's meant to be more of a
secret Wars teaser and eventually we will see
versions of them slowly cameo in other future
movies some of them won't come back permanently
some of them will just be cameos but that's the
whole reason why they tease Valhalla in another
dimension like oh they're all still here they can
come back to the main MCU Dimension eventually
the the Hercules post-credissing is really just
about setting up the next Thor movie not
so much about Avengers 5 King Dynasty or
Avengers 6 Secret Wars but Hercules might
also appear in secret Wars in a cameo too
yes father because every character in the history
of Marvel is supposed to have some kind of cameo
in that movie like think the portal scene from
Avengers end game times 100 you want more yes
yes we wanted more burning every single
character ever even Howard the Duck was
in the portal scene in Avengers end game so if
Howard the Duck made it into the first version
of that you have to imagine the most obscure
of characters will probably make it into the
secret Wars version of that but when Zeus tells
Hercules to go kill Thor and creates this larger
plan to make the Lesser beings normal people
fear the gods again because the whole theme
in the movie is that people have turned away
from the gods they also address that during
Moon night as well way fewer people across
the universe believe in Gods so it was a way
to make the people fear them again Zeus is having
Hercules kill Thor in broad daylight so to speak
they will fear us again when thor odinson falls
from the sky it is more of a Thor versus all the
other gods kind of movie like a war of Realms
type of conflict a mini version of Avengers
Infinity war and Avengers endgame where it's
all about Thor first the rest of the Gods which
is kind of funny because that's kind of what
they set Thor love and thunder up to be like
Gore versus all the other gods during that movie
Thor even jokes about how all the other gods are
going to hate them and want to kill them now
now they're just paying that off like oh yeah
they're definitely coming to try and kill you
in the comics Hercules was meant to be about as
powerful as Thor just like Thor in the comics
too he also gained greater Cosmic levels of
power to become God of gods Rune King Thor is a
good example of that like Thor becoming the God
of all gods that's how powerful he was during
chaos War more recently in the comics Hercules
also became God of all gods so even though their
powers work very differently they're kind of the
same power level basically even if you haven't
read a lot of Hercules comics in the past MCU
Hercules powers are similar to a lot of the other
pop culture depictions of Hercules he starts out
as a demigod son of Zeus in a human woman and
throughout his adventures attains more power
and eventually has to choose whether to live the
rest of his existence as a full-on god like 100
percent God or pull a Thor in Avengers end game
and just continue having Adventures on his own on
ground level Thor's Ark in the MCU has been pretty
much that like do you accept your responsibility
to become king of your people become more of an
actual God to your people or do you just continue
having fun Across the Universe now what do I do
since Chris Hemsworth is saying that that next
Thor movie versus Hercules and the gods is meant
to be his last time as the character most people
think that means that Hercules is going to be
successful in killing him but I don't think that
that's what they're going with also I think that
Chris Hemsworth is being a little misleading when
he's saying he's leaving the character like Hugh
Jackman left Wolverine after Logan Patrick Stewart
also left Professor X after Logan but here they
are playing their characters again a lot Deadpool
3 is like a full-on Deadpool and Wolverine
movie based on countless other examples of stuff
like this happening in previous movies my early
Theory right now is that when Hercules and Thor
start the movie battling it out eventually they'll
have their quote-unquote Martha moment post all
the memes like Thor will convince Hercules that
they're both Total Bros they're the two biggest
hymbos in the Marvel Universe why wouldn't they
become drinking Bros at some point and they'll
have a similar Arc with their relationship in
the movies that they did in the comics like when
Hercules was first introduced in the comics he
became more of a foil for Thor they battled it
out quite a bit eventually they became good
friends and just started having lots of fun
together just let's go around smash a bunch
of alien cultures and then get really drunk
afterwards and by the end of his last movie he
will accept the greater Cosmic role and become
a little bit more like Rune King Thor in the way
he fit within the Marvel Universe in more of a god
of God's Cosmic kind of role and that'll be how
they explain why Thor isn't around day to day all
the time for regular movies anymore but how he
can still come back for cameos occasionally in
the future when they really want him leaving room
for Hercules in the MCU to eventually fill Thor's
role on that new Avengers team like he did in the
comics I honestly they put a chip in my brain they
were explode if I answer any of your questions and
then I don't get to do anything during the first
Red Hulk Arc in the comics which we're getting
ready for in the MCU the incredible Hercules title
even took over for the Thor book in the comics
we're getting ready for Ant-Man 3 Quantum Mania
Kane the Conqueror is appearing in that for the
first time I think that'll be the version that
we see in Avengers 5 Kane Dynasty a lot of the
plot of Kang Dynasty is based on Avengers King
war in the comics which is a little bit different
but a lot of the new Avengers team in Kang war is
The Avengers team that we're going to see in the
MCU like Hercules is on the team Falcon Captain
America was on the team Spider-Man was on the
team Spider-Man is still going to be on the MCU
version of The Avengers team during Avengers 5
and Avengers 6. we'll also have gotten Spider-Man
4 before that happens so I know there's lots
of questions about what the spell changed with
Spider-Man and The Avengers it didn't change
him fighting with the Avengers or being on the
Avengers team they just forgot that Peter Parker
is the person underneath Spider-Man's mask they
haven't announced any kind of release date for
that Thor vs Hercules movie that they're setting
up or how many other gods are going to be in that
movie unless they announce that they're starting
work on it next year they wouldn't be able to get
it out until after Avengers 6 Secret Wars he will
be in Avengers 5 and Avengers 6 Secret Wars and
then after that they'll do that Thor vs Hercules
movie and then after that he pulls more of a huge
actman Wolverine where he only comes back every
once in a while but post all your predictions for
that Thor vs Hercules movie in the comments below
who else do you want to see in that movie I just
did a brand new Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special Guardians of the Galaxy 3 video I'll put
a link for that in the description below we also
got the Loki season 2 trailer recently I did
a breakdown of that so I'll link at the end of
this and the TVA is also going to be a really
big deal during Deadpool 3. I just did a video
for that as well so there'll be a lot of Loki and
Thor related stuff happening during Marvel Phase
5 Marvel phase six everyone click here for that
brand new Deadpool 3 video to learn about what's
going on with the TVA during that movie and
click here for my Loki season 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!